I guys, this is Tim Ferriss. Going
to cover some basics of dog training.
I'm not a dog trainer,
but I thought I would share what I've
learned from going over 2030 books and
working with a number of trainers.
The first is a prerequisite skill.
This is Molly. Good Molly.
So the prerequisite skill
number one is attention.
You want to get eye contact,
and I have mentioned this once before,
but this is how this works.
So let's just say she comes over
prerequisite skill number two.
I'll show you what this is is.
So that's called hand targeting.
We're going to talk
about that in a second,
but let's just say we come down
and pretending that she's not.
This is a clicker pretending that
she's no, no, that's a different trick.
Then we have eye contact
and you go out to the side.
She looks at me and I give her the treat.
All right.
So I am training her to
constantly check in with her eyes
and the clicker makes it very fast,
very consistent because if
you're like nice doggy, good
doggy, Yay, Molly, whatever,
it's not consistent and it's not going
to impart the conditioning that you want.
Okay. The way that that
then develops, leave it.
Okay.
So then you can start to instill self
control in your dog and discipline.
This is very,
very important for safety.
Now she might have some water
because this stuff is dry.
So you can see the,
okay,
the [inaudible] is a stop
or the eye as a stop. Uh,
I was also negative reward marker.
I'm going to get to that.
But the hand targeting is number two.
So first in India,
she's constantly checking in with me,
looking at me, waiting, waiting, waiting.
And I'll have her sit to
say please for everything.
So if we come over, Yup. Okay.
And then down. Up. All right,
so sit is pleased. That's true.
Coming out of the door. That's true.
Getting out of the car before going
through a door. Always. I have her sit,
I walk through.
I always go through first,
then she checks with me and then okay,
and that's the release word.
And there's a lot of debate about
using okay as the release word,
I think it's fine. 99 times out of 999
times out of a thousand. All right,
so hand targeting and this is
something you can do very easily with,
say puppies also get them used to poking
your hand with their nose and you use
the clicker to tell them when
they're doing it correctly.
So if you want it to get a dog to heel,
for instance,
you could put peanut butter on your hand
and I haven't done this with her so it
may not work.
But watch if I do this,
she'll follow the hand and then poke it
with their nose and then I gave her a
treat. So it would have clicked. Right?
If you're working with a puppy and trying
to get it to follow the taste on your
hand,
that's a very good way to train heel.
You can also do it with a wall on this
opposite side. Very, very common. Okay.
But still is kind of a, a
vanity trick. All right,
I'll show you another vanity trick.
Okay.
Yeah. So she's, she
loves jumping into heal.
But another vanity trick would be stay
stay as a safety trick. Okay. So safety
behaviors, safety tricks and number one,
vanity trek or something like
this. I thought, all right.
Okay. So high fives and catches
do not keep the dog alive,
but they might impress a dinner guest
or something like that. Right? So down
I do like rollover, that kind
of stuff. Also vanity tricks,
very simple stuff.
And uh,
but I'll show you how we would use a
clicker to teach something like rollover.
Okay. And then this is true for many
different tricks and it's a progression.
It's really just conditioned
response. Okay. Down is,
so she knows this trick obviously already,
but you would use the food to get the dog
to follow your hand like this and then
click as they get closer
and closer to the behavior,
they don't have to complete it first.
They just have to make an inch of progress
in the right direction. Click, click,
click. And then eventually
you would fade the lure.
So you lose the food
and use the same motion,
give the food, and then you start to
make it smaller and smaller. Sorry.
It's sorry food. It's like sign
language. It's conditioned now. Uh,
and that way you get to the point where
you can do something. For instance,
another vanity trick would be turning,
right? So you get your doctor's spin.
Now you start by using the food to get
them to follow it and then you get to the
point. So this is her default.
This is a new default behavior. Um,
when I walk with her outside and
I do a lot of off leash training,
but you can see that the spin,
I just need this type of emotion.
And it started off like this,
getting rid of bu effectively
chase their tail staying.
And you do the same thing where as you
provide the food and get them to move
their body or head in a certain way and
then you lose the food and then you make
it smaller. You can get them to do
things like any Molly take a bath.
So as to take the bow, uh, and, and,
and you can really get
creative with this stuff.
The clicker is incredibly important.
And Karen Pryor don't shoot the dog.
And then command performance are really,
really helpful.
But let's just say using the clicker,
I'll show you some stuff you can do.
You can,
you can get into very what people might
think of a sophisticate behaviors.
These are actually really simple. So
cute. Alright. And then let's say she's,
I want her to do a quarter
turn. Okay. Quarter term.
So a quarter turns pretty easy. Let's
say we want to do backwards turn, okay.
Or I want to do through the
legs, spin around, back to heal.
And then let's say she's a little
bit too far forward back girl.
So, so those are some basic
trick that you can see.
She's very well behaved and if I give her,
say good about.
All right, so let's say this
was something poisonous. Okay,
I'll give her one just cause
she went to bed, but okay,
leave it.
All right,
so let's just say that was something
covered with paint or arsenic or some
miscellaneous object.
On the side of the road.
I want to be able to keep
her from eating that,
which I can do because we've practiced
all of this hundreds and thousands of
times, and then she checks in and I go,
okay. And then she can eat it. Right?
So priority number one with training
your dog is keeping your dog safe.
Priority number two is keeping other
people safe prior to number three is
entertainment or anything else.
Okay?
So those are some of the
basics of doctrinal. Be Nice,
be consistent, and good luck. Thanks for
watching guys. I hope you enjoyed it.
And if you want to see more,
I have some fantastic stuff coming,
including collaborations. Just click
here and you'll be the first to see it.